[Music]
what does that mean truth is i'm
supposed to be in prison for what
superhero stuff what superhero are you
peacemaker get out of here there's no
superhero called peacemaker dude i'm
famous
[Music]
you're a born killer with expertise in
every weapon under humankind
i'm giving you the chance to stay out of
prison and work for me kill people bad
people
this is hardcore
you don't have to shoot people after
kill them
right
who's the guy that's peeking out behind
the trash can vigilante's trying to be
helpful
our first target is senator royal and
golf dolph may be traveling with his
family
are you sure those two kids came out of
those parents that's an attractive
couple that one looks like it came out
of them but the other one looks good
baby baby yeah my older brother told me
there's two types of babies one that
comes off normal and then butt babies
worst in every way they come out of a
woman's butt
well i believed i was a butt baby until
i was like 14. that explains a lot
there's something about him that's
sad
hey dude
i didn't mind sprung up going to a nancy
boy like you
no lately i'm just like a maniac hey no
no that's because we're born killers
what separates us from other killers is
we only kill bad people
usually
unless there's a mistake
you use being a jerk is a way to push
people away
but if you just drop that
people actually might like you
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
oh my god
he's he's hugging me
he's hugging me dad grab my phone i
don't want to move
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you